a new study released by a Pew and the
internet and american life project has
revealed that basically we are now
self-censoring ourselves so this isn't
about the government this isn't about
people talking about you we're actually
doing it to ourselves and let's look at
the study's findings from Rutgers
University they found that while
eighty-six percent of Americans would be
willing to have a conversation about an
issue in person just forty two percent
of Facebook and Twitter users were
willing to post about it so this is your
you'll do something actually in person
when it's not supposedly being recorded
but then you don't really want to make
your statement when it's going to stick
around for a while and then if people
think their opinions would be well
received they're more likely to post
about the topic but even the thought
that some of their followers and friends
might disagree led many to self-censor
so I think this is really really
fascinating because we do all this stuff
online we put all this stuff out there
we're all on Facebook and Twitter and
Instagram and everything else and we're
doing it to ourselves it's not just the
government doing it to us as a comedian
you you put stuff out there you're
supposed to you're paid to say what you
think do you do any of this do you
partake in the self-censorship I do I
think the difference is like I said if
I'm talking to a person and we're
talking about something that's pretty
dark and would agitate others even if I
make a blanket statement about something
you might give me you know a response
and I'm like all you might have a point
but if you put something just cold on
Twitter or Facebook then you're drawing
people that you don't even know and then
people just lose their minds and so
there's no give and take yeah and and
because it's Twitter because it's
Facebook like a text you can't read
exactly how people are meaning stuff
some stuff you don't need to read
exactly it is pretty foul yeah but but I
do think that's the reason if I put
something up and then people I'll take
it down just because it's not a real
back and forth discussion and and if I
do learn something from and I'm like
like my position on that I kind of
changed my mind cuz someone gave me a
piece of information that made me change
my mind then it's out there now and
people you know it's not forgiving like
it's a conversation between you and I
now it's out there and it's on you for
their forever forever they're watching
you forever self-censor I do you do it
the soft sensor it's funny I have done
it and the most recent example I could
give is I so I think that there was a
movie that came out recently called
boyhood by richard linklater who i think
is a genius he's a genius I didn't think
the movie was that good but it had like
a ninety-nine percent on rotten tomatoes
and everybody that I know was just
raving about it I don't think it was I
good I was like debating whether or not
to tweet that I really didn't think I
was that impressive and I opted not to
tweet it because for a number of reasons
because I felt like it was you know Anna
maybe I was missing something you know
obviously I self censored you know I
didn't say what I really felt but then
um you know I thought to myself that I'm
such a fan of his anyway that why would
I want to like say something not nice
about his work well first off thank you
for unselfish answering right now you
didn't want to do it on Twitter you were
willing to do it on YouTube that's
interesting to talk to your therapist
about that yeah do you think it's partly
because of all the apologies that we see
celebrities having to make that's when I
was reading this that's what I kept
thinking like everybody now immediately
says something at apologies and we can
we can list them all you know from duck
dynasty on down do you think that people
that regular citizens are eventually
going to be held to the same standards
that all the public people aren't I
think I think that's part of it what's
going on here people are afraid that
their boss is going to see something you
know back you know this is what you're
talking about about the difference
between a one-on-one conversation and a
public thing but you should be allowed
to have your own political views or
views on social stuff without the fear
that you know your boss is going to see
it and get fire you know getting
firewood look if you if you're working
at a Burger King let's just say yeah and
your people are at the register and
you're spouting some religious ideology
you know in me but that's not correct
either but if you're on social media and
your boss is on your facebook I mean you
have to expect that people are going to
be negative
about that as much as they're going to
be positive about that it's it's there
forever and it will follow you forever
so if you are working at Burger King
let's use the example per second if
you're working at Burger King obviously
you can't do it right to their faces but
if you then have a Twitter account that
has your real name on it and maybe it
does let's say it doesn't say that you
work at Burger King but and you're
writing some crazy [ __ ] you like your
for the KKK I don't know should Burger
King bail out to fire you even if you
don't say you work for Burger King but
it's but they know with the simple
Google search yeah yeah it's good we're
slightly off topic yet no I think I
think that people should be held
accountable for their for their actions
online for sure yeah I would be curious
to know what it is about you know
presenting a differing opinion that
people are actually afraid of is that
they're afraid of being the ugly
duckling or are they afraid of not
getting as many likes like there are few
confounding variables in there that I
feel like should be yeah yeah is it also
that we just live in a crazy time right
now as we've been talking about with all
this I like we have so much stuff
between Middle East and Ebola and NSA
and like just all this crazy stuff that
I do sense online now people are just
yelling at each other constantly and I
do try my best to follow people I don't
like almost as much as I follow people I
like and sometimes I don't succeed in i
unfollow people because i can't take it
anymore but like i try to because i
don't want to live in that echo chamber
do you try to follow some people that
you don't agree with I do because
because putting stuff on Facebook and
Twitter I mean for me the thing that I
have the most fear of getting called out
is not being knowledgeable enough about
what I'm talking about you know so I did
never stopped anybody else see what but
I don't want to embarrass myself in that
way of just that I am NOT well read
enough about a certain subject so but
that being said I mean I do think that
people should be held more responsible
for what they're saying and to not to
just the public to themselves and not
just to be talking on other but you know
to that point when this whole uzd thing
happened with on the mountain a couple
of weeks ago I tweeted that
at something like you know the CD are
trapped on a mountain Isis is about to
kill them the world doesn't care it got
1,800 retweet it was the number one
retweeted thing about the Yazidi and
then we had air strikes the next day I
was like wow maybe my little tweet had
something do this the picture that I
attached to it was was a prong picture
it was from Syria from like two years
before so I made a mistake and it's like
then I did issue a retraction for that
but like delete the tweet vote I did
until he can't breathe I mean at that
many retweets you can drink so I guess
that was the message here don't delete a
tweet if you have that many retweets